if you want to hear how one dark detail
from the book was hidden in this
miniseries that stick around to the end
of this video this video is brought to
you by Ray's shadow legends if you've
seen some of my other it videos you know
that one of my favorite side characters
from the book is the foul-mouthed cab
driver and while we don't get to listen
to his banter and the miniseries part
two does open up with building dropped
off in a cab at a cemetery where he has
his first encounter with penny wise
since returning to Derry this seems to
be a reference to stand being the one
out of the Lucky seven who already died
although it would have been more
accurate if penny wise had given him a
Jewish grave marker after this encounter
bill visits Mike at the library where
there is a table set up dedicated to his
works as an author the title knock could
be a reference to the unnamed werewolf
novel that Stan wife was reading in the
book and the glowing could either be a
reference to the glowing dead lights or
a parody of one of Stephen King's well
known books The Shining meanwhile Richie
Tozier is rolling into town singing the
Beach Boys notices his own epitaph on
the movie theater marquee this is a
reimagining of a scene in the book where
he finds a similar inscription on a rock
concert poster in the park he runs into
the library to find Mike but instead
finds Pennywise who is reading the
finance section of the newspaper this is
supposed to be a joke about its name
being Pennywise really got his back at
Mike's house the boys are rediscovering
Bill's old bike silver and Mike brings
out the playing cards that's just any
cards by shape they always made the best
noise bill and Mike noticed something is
wrong when they see to ace of spades and
the penny wise design on the back of the
car it's very similar to the book where
they opened a brand new deck but there
were blue and red backed cards mixed in
with each other it is about this time
that Ben arrives in Derry and goes down
into the Barrens where he sees a fat boy
getting bullied giving him flashbacks to
his childhood he helps fix up the boys
scraped knee oh oh no that cannot be
sanitary
it's basically pissing so I'm just
telling you Eddie is the next to arrive
back in town he visits the pharmacy
where he picks up his asthma medication
and runs into mr. keen the pharmacist
from when he was young but this is only
another example of Pennywise
manipulating the town of Derry mr. Keene
grabs on to Eddie using a hand covered
in the crunchy exoskeleton like that of
the spider clawed at the seven of them
drove away as kids the last to arrive is
Beverly Marsh who visits her father's
old home there are three names next to
the doorbells of this town hats Marsh
Bert and Starkweather Burton
Starkweather are the family names of the
second and third floor icons of
Beverly's apartments in the book this
house doesn't appear to have a third
floor but maybe Starkweather is around
the back here
I've still got to applaud the accuracy
of that small detail from the novel when
Beverly gets away mrs. Kirsch transforms
into the clown off screen and we hear
that same noise heard when Richie's
werewolf turns into penny wands which is
also heard by Stan later on in the
sewers the remaining members of the
Lucky seven would reconvene for a
reunion dinner where even more hidden
details can be uncovered viewers of my
channel have already been flocking to
Playa rage shadow legends the new free
RPG taking the mobile landscape by storm
this mega hit of a game takes you inside
of a dark fantasy world with more than
ten million other players worldwide who
have enjoyed this game for the last six
months get ready to get real dark and
Evan Rachel Legends is a mobile
experience that has everything you'd
expect from a triple-a RPG title it has
over 400 champions to collect a fully
voiced story campaign and the ability to
Cline up with the boys and raid with
friends with more than 300,000 reviews
on the Play Store it has a nearly
perfect score they have huge plans for
updates over the next 6 months like new
faction a tag team arena feature and a
new
fine box use my link in the description
to start with 50,000 silver and a free
epic champion as part of the new player
program
remember bills wife Audra of the actress
she's extremely concerned about her
husband after his son and Trackbacks is
airing and she meets with the movie
producer about his sudden disappearance
from the sect you've worked very hard to
get where you are very hard I know you
do nothing to jeopardize that or to
damage our professional relationship
also turn a friend overnight into a
violent enemy ready to crucify you want
any caution
whoa that escalated so fast wake up grab
a brush and put a little makeup Ritchie
has a momentary panic attack after
realizing his old friends are all grown
up now and stops in the bathroom to get
a hold of himself I recently noticed
that he knocks over the artwork in the
bathroom and never fixes it after the
introductions they discuss penny whines
maybe that means he's afraid it's afraid
this little correction is a reference to
a more significant detail in the book
being that the creature it's is actually
a female something that Audra discovers
upon being taken to the spiders lair the
writers woman had put out one powerful
horrified thoughts oh dear Jesus it is
female and then all thoughts cease Eddie
is the only one whose memory about what
happens when his children has yet to
come back and after hearing the word
sewer the cloud over his memories
dissipates in a rush I think I remember
who penny wise was now big white guy red
nose about 75 feet tall 75 feet tall no
what are you talking about Eddie he was
never 75 feet tall the six of them
decided to save the serious topic of
conversation for later and enjoy their
meal and the music during the food
montage is the same song from the
building of the dam 30 years ago because
they're rebuilding those bonds that they
had formed together as children after
chowing down they get to discussing the
reason that they all came back to dairy
the promise that they would eradicate
Pennywise once more the camera circles
around them in the scene giving the
viewer a sense of disorientation as they
recall more and more disturbing things
from their past their heads are spinning
trying to process it all and the
cinematography reflects that finally
their fortune cookies arrive and each
cookie contains something that
represents one of their fears Beverley's
is the blood like the blood from her
father saying Eddie's is a roach a bug
associated with poor
and somewhat similar to his adults fear
from the book that rickets in its
basement Ritchie's is an eyeball because
he was always bullied for his glasses
his kid Mike's is a bird hatchling
referencing his fear of the giant bird
that attacked him in the book I honestly
have no idea what Ben's is but Bill's
seems to be a spider yet another clue
about the eventual final form that it
would take and these six would come to
face after fleeing the restaurant they
continue their meeting at the library
where they try to get ahold of Stan and
learn about his death bill recalls
Stan's childhood encounter with it as
further evidence of how stan was so
deeply affected by the monster in the
flashback Stan wanders into an old house
not only is the scene a substitute for
Stan's horrifying journey into the
standpipe in the book where he gets
trapped inside of the water storage
structure in a similar way and has to
use his bird book to free himself but I
think the house itself is supposed to be
29 me bolt Street an abandoned dolt
property that serves as its bridge
between the sewers and the surface we
don't fully see the figure that left a
permanent scar on Stan's memories but
from what we do see it appears to be a
mummy in the clown suit this was likely
supposed to be the same mummy that Ben
encounters in the novel on the canal
bridge and finds to be much more
disturbing than Boris Karloff's
depiction of the mummy in the 1932 film
Pennywise tries to scare them off by
hitting the library with an indoor
thunderstorm so they gather up the
supplies that mike is organized and head
to the hotel that Bill Eddie and Ritchie
Beverly and Ben are staying at the stuff
Mike collected consists of boxes of hard
hats pairs of boots and flashlights the
hard hats never actually get used though
throughout the night Pennywise contacts
Henry Bowers who is locked up in juniper
Hill insane asylum as a figure that
appears to him through the moon the
guard at the asylum is named Kunz named
after Stephen King's rival Jenkins a
fellow horror author when it appears
before Koons he drops a roll of quarters
the miniseries never explains why but in
the novel quarters are used as a form of
punishment on the patients to the asylum
it was illegal for the guards who were
called counselors here at juniper Hill
to carry billy clubs so a number of them
foggerty Adler and Koontz were the worst
carried rolls of quarters in their
pockets they almost always hit you with
them in the same place right in the back
of the neck there was no rule against
quarters quarters were not considered a
deadly weapon at juniper Hill back at
the inn Mike hands out copies of his
collection of newspaper headlines
corresponding to the tragic events and
is past the first headline reads black
spike club burns a story about the
nightclub that Mike's father narrowly
escaped in the novel I'm back there's a
piece on Jerry's lost settlers the book
tells of an irish group of settlers
named the dairy company that disappeared
without leaving a trace before the town
as we know it was established there are
a couple of mistakes on this paper for
example the date listed is April 26 1960
which was a Tuesday not a Wednesday the
content of the articles doesn't
correspond to what's teased in the
headlines either in fact the clickbait
is so strong here you think these
articles were written by land stewards
this one is about the Arctic and this
one's about politics or something as
they all leave the hotel for the last
time the woman at the desk has a few
copies of bills book the glowing and
what looks to be a vinyl with Ritchie's
name and face on it she's got a pen
ready as if she's about to ask for
autographs but they all leave so quickly
that she doesn't have the chance before
stepping out bill sees a woman in a
child's playing Fur Elise by Beethoven
this is the same song his mother always
used to play
[Music]
[Applause]
what remains of the group hacks into
Ritchie's car to drive down to the sewer
and take down penny woman's the model of
this car is iroc-z perhaps chosen a
signified Ritchie's love for rock and
roll when they get down into the sewer
pipes spiderwebs cover the walls a grim
clue about the creature that they would
face later that night the first form of
its they encounter is Bill's deceased
little brother Georgie although we never
see Georgie's death on screen the child
is missing his right arm a reminder for
fans of the book of the disturbing
method of his death where his arm is
dismembered in the cavern we finally
discover the meaning of its catchphrase
you'll float to the bodies of the
victims float over the chamber strung up
in the spider's webbing also there's the
fact that this is clearly a painting but
who's to say it doesn't have a taste for
the Fine Arts it is at this point that I
would have liked for everyone to realize
that Bill's wife is the movie star Audra
Phillips and yell out hey it got the
lady from blood Christmas yeah that
doesn't happen though the original plan
for this final boss battle was to have
Tim Curry the man who played penny wise
in control of the spider somehow but
that didn't pan out so instead the only
resemblance is when the creature briefly
flashes it's carnivorous teeth just like
the clown is sometimes seem to have then
this happened
[Music]
but believe in the Easter Bunny I
believe in the tooth fairy
Andy what are you saying you're a virgin
and they beat it and they kill the
monster I love this miniseries but that
isn't my favorite part as things wrap up
we learned that Richie Tozier got into
movies after returning to Hollywood the
movie that he's shown shooting is on
scene 574 oh my god that is a long movie
and I thought it was long there's also
an Easter egg on the slate the
cinematographer Ritchie's movie Jay Baer
is ook is the name of the script
supervisor in it
bill is still rehabilitating his wife
when it's time to leave if the same cab
driver from way back at the beginning
picks him up but he wants to try one
more thing first to try to save Audra
and takes her first spin on his old bike
silver this bike saved little Stan's
life one's mine too we were going so
fast I think we beat the devil like in
at chapter 2 this is an audible
reference to the epilogues chapter
top-billed then burro beats the devil
the film goes to black and everyone gets
their happy ending or do they over the
credits
Pennywise is laughter can be heard
continuing to reverberates would this
imply that Pennywise lives on after this
second defeat at the hands of bill has
been enriching the ideas explored more
in stephen king's other books so make
sure you watch my horror history episode
on Pennywise to find out but before you
move on make sure you subscribe to seize
these worlds for new Horrors every week
ring that death Bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]